this is true's first time to disneyland
what do you get for your fourth birthday
when you're khloe kardashian's daughter
there's way more pressure but it's
exciting a full day of fun at disneyland
with your cousins that's what i think it
works and get this the reality star
confirmed those photoshop theories from
december but first let's unpack true's
special day it's just a ball coco and
her sister kim kardashian took the kids
to the happiest place on earth tuesday
and naturally they documented the whole
thing on social media
who said i'm taking a picture i'm taking
a video
look at shirts
let me see is it amazing
kim's four-year-old daughter chicago was
there so was rob kardashian's
five-year-old daughter dream who
adorably revealed her wish to her auntie
klow
[Music]
the kiddos ate churros hit up all the
classic rides and said hi to a few of
their favorite disney characters
[Music]
kids like really
really really love elsa don't they
[Music]
i don't know how you're gonna top that
oh but i do
kim shared this clip during her tour
through it's a small world featuring
jasmine and aladdin dolls
[Music]
seems to be a not so subtle nod to her
boyfriend pete davidson
oh my god the two started dating after
the 41 year old hosted saturday night
live in october and shared their first
kiss in this disney parody
i mean i like you just the way you are
now are you gonna kiss me or not
i sure am jasmine
what's your favorite thing about him
he's just super genuine and it's just
really fun to just
hang out and do nothing and
watch tv and just do nothing
what do you all love about pete i love
that he's
kind and really really thoughtful he's
the most thoughtful person and i love
the chemistry that kim and him have
together it's really sweet i thought you
said the chemistry i was like okay
chemistry
chemistry
okay but back to true
the disney outing had fans in full-on
social media detective mode and guys
they solve the mystery genuinely i
cannot believe it let me explain back in
december kim shared this snap of what
appears to be shy and true at the theme
park cute right well the kkw beauty
founders followers were suspicious of
true's placement in the pic saying it
was giving off major copy and paste
slash photoshop vibes so we'll just have
to wait and see
right and on tuesday chloe proved their
hunch was true pun intended
this is true's first time to disneyland
first time to disneyland eh
this is true's first time to
disneyland man you guys are good i know
and chloe confirmed it herself tweeting
quote welp i [ __ ] this one up anyways
let's focus on something else our show
airs in a few days tristan and i are
complicated
trust takes time e.t spoke with the
famous fam about the new show
specifically how they chose the parts of
their lives to share
i think for every sister we have
different boundary levels and we all try
to respect that your boundaries are
allowed to change and mine will probably
change later but
what is in the media is sort of things
that we feel we need to film because
it's in a way unfair to the viewers if
they don't get to see that we've shared
so much about our lives
[Music]